hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft ich befinde mich gerade auf
dem kasteler server weil wir hier eine
runde lucky blog wars spielen werden
trifft die fifty chance auf epics new
york rangers lucky blog zu episch an und
da ich in dem video gestern was ich euch
hier nochmal verlinken da habe ich am
ende gesagt da bin ich auf ein paar
bissen konstruktive kritik an einem
kanal der zeit eingegangen deswegen
wollte ich das video heute einfach ein
bisschen länger halten und mal wieder
über zwei drei themen kurz reden die bei
mir derzeit zum bisschen anstehen wo ich
allerdings als community mit einbeziehen
wollte erst mal zur erklärung des
spielmodus und zwar wurde ich gerade
diese map hier rein gebohrt die passe
regen wir haben vier items und können
hier mit dieses porsches abbauen die hab
ich überhaupt ziehen und wir können halt
allgemein auch alle anderen blogger
abbauen also sei es holz oder irgendwas
anderes und können uns auch in sachen
tragen auch hier sind sponge wenn ich
ihnen jetzt abo haben wir beispielsweise
danke für diese tolle items ich liebe
lucky blog ich wollte mir die galle
nehmen weil ich dachte dass ich mich
damit rüber bauen kann aber die sind
alle einzeln genannt und ich kann die
deswegen nicht stecken
es ist sehr schön nächsten lucky blog
haben wir irgendwas was soll das wieso
explodiert meine verpackte hensel es
gibt halt leute in dem spiel die
wirklich glück haben mit ich auch das
ist doch nicht wahr ich krieg schon
wieder so eine neue kiste es gibt leute
die wirklichen ursachen haben wie
beispielsweise der typ der mich mit
irgendeinem explosiven zeug abgeschossen
hat von da hinten und es gibt auch leute
wie mich ziehenden creeper crêpes und
ich bin tot jedenfalls wollte ich heute
über zwei themen reden die mich derzeit
so ein bisschen beschäftigen und danach
wie ich kann das cool damit verbinden da
in der letzten folge viele meinten dass
die videos mal länger werden sollten und
ich mal anstatt zu kompletten schneiden
wir wieder so wie früher einfach mal ein
bisschen was lagern sollte ganz frech
und chili und zwar fange ich einfach mal
über die erste sache zu reden während
wir noch 60 sekunden warten bis die
zweite runde hier losgeht ich wurde
angeschrieben von einem sehr großen
deutschen unternehmen ob ich mit denen
zusammen ein werbevideo machen möchte
eine produktfertigung habe ich
beispielsweise mal gemacht vom bitte das
sind ja drehen wollten diamanten seine
erste rolle eine produktplatzierung habe
ich beispielsweise mal gemacht als ich
für die serie mister robert die ich
selber auch übel feier und schon auf
englisch was diese stadt ist einfach
eine serie gefeiert habe und da habe ich
mir gedacht okay das ist ein hacker
serie
die partner haben dieses mal kann ich
auch meine sachen kriegen die verlinke
ich euch mal hier da habe ich einfach
ein hacker spiel gespielt weils ein
hacker serie war und konnte das deswegen
ganz cool integrieren und ich falle die
serie selbst und das ist quasi eine
produktplatzierung ein werbevideo habe
ich so eigentlich noch nie auf youtube
gemacht das haben eigentlich schon alle
anderen youtube einmal gemacht und ich
hab's bei dehner gesehen weil sarrazin
bei weil tt bei alle haben es eigentlich
irgendwie schon mal gemacht bei einem
werbevideo geht es wirklich darum dass
das komplette video dieser einen sache
diesem unternehmen oder dem produkt
gewidmet ist und man selber quasi nicht
so viele freiheiten hat bezüglich der
video gestaltung ich hoffe ich konnte
das jetzt irgendwie gut erklären ganz
locker und kurz um es kurz zu fassen ich
habe die möglichkeit bekommen ein
werbevideo zu machen
in einem großen deutschen unternehmen
was ich euch noch nicht sagen möchte und
noch nicht sagen
jetzt fragt ihr euch natürlich was habt
ihr davon ich habe die möglichkeit mit
einem professionellen 360 grad
die mit einer der besten 360 grad
kameras es gibt einen 360° video
aufzunehmen und auf meinem kanal
hochzuladen da ich allerdings nicht
jemand bin der sagt hey ich brauche geld
ich will etwas nach oben
warum
natürlich ist geld schön und ich glaube
jeder von uns mal geld aber ich möchte
euch überlassen weil ihr seid die die
meine was ist das freundin klicks haben
ich habe auch die skizze sie sind tot
kann ich die nicht theoretisch mal
hierhin machen damit meinen boden so ein
bisschen wells ecken slater ich habe es
wirklich nur für meine eigene insel
gerade verbraucht jeder von uns mal geld
klar das ist gar keine frage allerdings
möchte ich es euch entscheiden lassen
weil nicht dass ihr denkt ich verkaufe
mich komplett und macht total -paket
manchmal total welten irgendwelche
werbevideos und normalerweise kriege ich
da wirklich auf wöchentlich zehn
milliarden anfragen fügen den cut
werbung zu machen und ich lebe
eigentlich 99 7 prozent ab allerdings
ist das wirklich eine sache wo ich mir
sage okay ich darf ein video hochladen
was kompletter sichtlich grad ist ich
habe die technik marke testet ich habe
mir selber meine kamera gestellt
allerdings nur so 1000 euro dinge oder
sohn und die haben dann halt wirklich
die möglichkeit irgendwie mit einer
fünfstelligen kamera irgendwie was zu
filmen und ich kann's hochladen die
sache ist halt da steht dann halten die
ganze werbevideo und das ganze ist für
neben dem unternehmen halt geprägt aber
ich habe die möglichkeit 360° ein video
hochzuladen und dann das mal auf meinem
kanal zu bringen
ihr könnt euch das cool anschauen und
wenn jeder lust drauf habt dann schreibt
einfach mal luca darf es gerne machen
aber wenn ihr sagt luca nein das ist ein
werbevideo bitte verkauft sich nicht
dann lehne ich es ab ich will die
entscheidung der komplett bei euch
lassen weil ihr wert quasi die community
ihr entscheidet was auf meinem kanal
gespielt wie ihr zweiter haltet ihr
davon ja da mach ich nehme dann links ab
das ist sache nur eins ich ansprechen
wollte sache nochmals weidig ansprechen
wollte bezog sich eigentlich nur ganz
auf meinen dass das hier was ich jeden
tag an hat und zwar gibt es ein neues
produkt im store was ich selber noch
nicht zu hause habe das ist nämlich das
t shirt was ich glaub ich hab sogar rat
hier ganz kurze story und zwar dieses t
shirt ist mein zweites lieblings t shirt
im shop das ist für dieses mal liegt
hier so aus dieser tasche quasi raus das
war die anfangs idee was ich eigentlich
nur machen wollte also ist auch und luca
level dran uns an unserem krams halt
hier ich wollte das allerdings direkt in
dem stoff machen dies jetzt im store als
ich blende euch jetzt mal ein bild davon
wie das derzeit hier in lucka shop
aussieht der shop es allerdings schon am
ersten zwölfter gelauncht und den stoff
haben wir erst jetzt mitte januar
bekommen deswegen ist es anfang februar
im shop enthalten deswegen hatten wir
erstes shirt in grau und schwarz gemacht
was ich selber wirklich nicht so schön
fand aber jetzt haben wir halt den neuen
stoff da und es scheint es echt nice ich
wollte mich hinsetze und ich hab ich
zeig ich sitze gerade auf der lehne ich
bin zu fest bei mir wird das shirt erste
halloween
bei mir wird das shirt erst in einer
woche oder so da sein glaube ich
woche da sein weil ich einfach nicht
selber etwas länger weg bin und die mir
das zu senden so dass ihr euch dann noch
mal echt zeigen kann allerdings nur
darüber informieren dass das jetzt im
shop enthalten ist ich komme mir auch
nie raus das gibt es jetzt im shop das
kann man dort kaufen
die shop adresse ist der village.de das
ist allerdings nicht die einzige sache
die ich euch ich will jetzt auch endlich
mal zu den gegnern aber irgendwie wie
conti soll ich denn da hin kommen ich
habe mir eine ender perle ganz ehrlich
alter baum ich jetzt einfach mit holz
hier schnell rüber also das ist nicht
der einzige sache die ich euch bezüglich
merge sagen wollte sondern auch mit
jetzt so oft geschrieben und ist so auf
dienstag an bilder wo ihr meinen smiley
selber auf irgendwelche handy hüllen
drauf klatscht und der kriege ich das
hin ich sehe halt voll auf bilder wie
ihr selber eigenen match macht mit einem
smiley wir das auf handy hüllen drauf
klatsch und das finde ich auch einfach
ultra nice und freue mich dann mal
drüber waterfall sich halt voll auf
immer bilder und denke mir dann so
eigentlich handy hüllen werden natürlich
schon nice aber ich will es eigentlich
nicht machen weil ich nicht so
kommerziell sein will deswegen habe ich
euch auch wegen dem werbevideo gefragt
ob er damit wirklich einverstanden seid
ich hatte halt überlegt irgendwie mal
über handy hüllen oder eventuell auch
bettwäsche weil da habe ich dass die
stadt hier hat er halt gedacht dass hier
so als bettwäsche also eine weiße
bettwäsche wo ganz auf dieser smiley
drauf ist wer bestimmt auch cool einfach
mal cup jeder ideen wenn ihre ideen hat
und das super cool ist dann schreibt mir
das einfach mal allerdings hier auch die
gleiche sache wenn ihr sagt hey uk com
wenn du jetzt auch das auch noch
verkaufen bis das wird echt geldgeil
dann werde ich auch lassen also ich
möchte da was solche sachen angeht
wirklich nur euch fragen und nicht dass
ich irgendwas hochladen weil ich die
selber teilweise youtube-kanäle die ich
total gefeiert habe die auf einmal nur
noch werbevideos um placement gemacht
haben fand ich selber nicht so nice
deswegen wollte ich euch dann komplett
zu fragen ob ihr da irgendwelche ideen
habt ob ihr da sagt ja das wäre cool
oder nein das ist nicht so cool und
schreibt mir das einfach mal zu dem
werbevideo was ich machen kann wo ihren
360 grad wieder bekommen und zu
merchandise was was euch dazu einfällt
und geht in lucca staiger hat ein neues
tiefe ringe alter macht ihr denn alles
für monster was ist denn das hier für
tot
ich würde mich da auf jeden fall mal
über eure meinung in den kommentaren
interessieren und ich bin froh dass ich
mir das dann durch reden kann und ich
hoffe auf eine gute konstruktive
unterhaltung in den kommentaren und ich
hoffe dass ich dieses etwas längere
video mal wieder gefallen hat wie
gefällt euch das reinschauen